la parole albéric de Montgolfier pour le
groupe UMP
merci Président
vous connaissez même pas la question
merci madame la garde des sceaux mes
chers collègues madame le garde des
sceaux parfois votre politique manque de
visibilité je pense en particulier au
débat sur la politique pénale et on le
dit souvent mais là je voudrais vous
interroger sur une question là aussi
nous a besoin de clarification qui est
celle de l'aide juridictionnelle les
juridictionnelle puisque on a bien
compris que vous ne souhaitiez pas
mettre le gouvernement dans l'embarras
et que vous avez donc décidé de reporter
la réforme de la juridictionnelle
au-delà de 2014 peut-être en 2015 et sur
le fond je dis clairement nous ne
pouvons qu'à prouver ce report ce recul
du gouvernement sur un sujet qui mettait
en difficulté à la fois la profession
d'avocat parce que la profession
d'avocats fait preuve parfois de la
véritable sens civique en travaillant
pour des sommes modestes au bénéfice des
plus démunis mais ça mettait également
en difficulté c'est très forme les
justiciables qui risquaient de voir
l'offre des services se réduire avec une
diminution des moyens
du fait des difficultés des cabinets qui
restent souffert d'une baisse de leur
moyen mais à disposition pour remplir
cette mission et pour autant malgré
cette reculade la question des
financement demeure toujours d'actualité
puisque le projet de loi de finance pour
2014 prévoit une baisse des crédits de
32 millions d'euros consacrés les
juridictionnaires c'est donc un problème
budgétaire qui met à même qui met à mal
pardon le principe même de la
juridictionnelle et vous êtes resté
madame la guerre des sous assez flou à
ce sujet et je en veux pour preuve vos
propos tenus de lors de l'assemblée
extraordinaire du Conseil national des
barreaux en disant je vous cite
explorons jusqu'au bout chaque piste à
charge pour vous de la récuser et je
crois que pour d'autre part nous ne
pouvons accepter que la Ministre en
charge en responsabilité sur ce sujet
sur ce sujet demande aux acteurs du
secteur en l'occurrence les avocats
d'assumer ce non choix alors ma question
est très simple pour être dans le temps
Madame et ministre faut-il encore
compter sur de nouvelles taxes
ou de nouveaux impôts pour financer la
refonte de l'ex juridictionnelle et en
tous les cas pouvez-vous nous éclairer
sur vos attentions sur les pistes que
vous envisagez pour réformer cette aide
juridictionnelle au-delà de l'année 2014
qui est celle de la passe budgétaire
merci madame la ministre
oui monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Sénateur trois procès en deux minutes
c'est un exploit alors je vais vous
répondre sur le flou du débat du débat
pénal pardon
pardon oui effectivement il y a une
grande différence de méthode entre ce
que vous faisiez et ce que nous faisons
nous ne réformons pas à l'encontre des
professions nous réformons avec les
professions nous respectons les
professions et nous travaillons avec
elle donc effectivement nous mettons des
pistes sur la table et nous discutons
nous concertons nous nous consultons les
professions de façon à aboutir de bonnes
réformes il y a plus de 10 ans qu'aucun
gouvernement n'a eu le courage de
réformer l'aide juridictionnelle et là
donc fragilisée la fragiliser mais nous
nous allons aboutir à une consolidation
une pérennisation du financement de
l'aide juridictionnelle parce que l'aide
juridictionnelle est tout simplement une
politique de solidarité vis-à-vis des
justiciables et plus vulnérables il n'y
en droit easy endroit en deçà même du
seuil de pauvreté par conséquent il faut
consolider cette politique de solidarité
donc nous le faisons nous continuons à
travailler vous savez que j'ai chargé
monsieur carré Pierra du d'une mission
qui permet effectivement de continuer la
discussion avec les professions de façon
aboutir avant le prochain budget à une à
un financement de l'aide
juridictionnelle vous n'avez pas dit un
quart de mot un quart de mots sur la
suppression des 35 euros que vous aviez
instauré et qui constitue une véritable
entrave à l'accès au juge et qui a
pénalisé des justiciables vulnérables
nous avons choisi d'abonder le budget de
la justice de 60 millions d'euros afin
de supprimer ce thème ce timbre de 35
euros merci mon cher collègue quelques
secondes si vous voulez bien très bien
je vous remercie Madame le Ministre de
mes manifester son attachement à la dur
d'Ixelles mais c'est après un budgétaire
puisque à 16h je rejoint la CMP à
l'Assemblée nationale et on va constater
quoi on va s'en douter dans la CMP mais
on va constater la baisse de 32 millions
d'euros consacrer les juridictionnelles
donc la réalité est là et quant aux
pistes et bien le question reste ouverte
et on sera très vigilant pour en
redébattre merci beaucoup merci